first coronavirus vaccine trial
involving pregnant women is underway in
the u.s
and around the world pfizer's study will
include 4
000 expecting mothers it will assess
vaccine safety and efficacy and look at
whether the vaccine can transfer
protective antibodies to newborns the
cdc says vaccines should be offered to
pregnant women
classifying pregnancy as a risk factor
for more severe
covate infections more than 51 thousand
pregnant women in the u.s have already
been vaccinated without waiting
for those trial results and i share a
household with one of them
nikki batiste is following these trials
nikki good morning to you
tony good morning pregnant women have
historically been excluded from initial
vaccine trials
due to concerns about risk to their
unborn babies which results in a lack of
safety data but the covet 19 pandemic
made these trials a priority
the women in this pfizer trial do not
know whether they're getting a vaccine
or a placebo we spoke with one expectant
mother just
after she received the first of her two
doses
have you had any severe reactions to any
vaccines no never
in her eighth month of pregnancy kelsey
carpenter rolled up her sleeve for a
shot at protection
all right just relax your arm okay not
just for her but more importantly she
says
for her unborn daughter are you worried
at all are you happy you're doing this
i'm happy i'm doing this i would be
totally
off base if i said i wasn't a little
nervous
the 28 year old from fort worth texas
who is already mom to a toddler
says she and her husband discuss the
vaccine extensively before signing up
at the end of the day it just seemed
like the best decision for me
and my family the pfizer trial will
include 4 000 healthy pregnant women
from at least 9 countries
who are between 24 to 34 weeks of
gestation
half will receive a placebo each woman
is asked to keep
a trial diary recording any symptoms
such as fever
dr cynthia robbins is carpenter's ob gyn
our hope is that by getting the vaccine
it transfers over the immunity through
the placenta to the baby
that seems to me like that would be a
really big deal it is a big deal because
their immune systems are so small
and weak so the only immunity they're
ever going to get when they're born is
from what mom
passed to them pregnant women are
prioritized for vaccines in at least 21
states but a recent poll in the u.s
found that more than half are reluctant
to sign up
citing concerns over lack of data as an
ob gyn were you nervous at all
to administer vaccines to pregnant women
no i wasn't
because i knew that the actual disease
the covid19 infection in pregnancy
was going to be worse than in the
general population
the american college of obstetricians
and gynecologists
recommends that covid19 vaccines not be
withheld from pregnant and nursing women
the cdc says no reports of miscarriages
stillbirths or preterm births have been
linked with the vaccines in women who
became pregnant
while participating in the initial
vaccine trials
if you're not happy to be in a trial
don't do it i'm just really excited that
pregnant women will have this chance to
be immunized
for us to make history with some answers
carpenter's daughter is helping pave the
way for future generations too
as part of the trial newborns will be
monitored for their first six months of
life
that's what sold me on it like okay this
could help my daughter
this can keep me safe it just seemed
like a win-win
there's at least one documented case in
the u.s of a baby born with covet 19
antibodies after its mother was
vaccinated when she was pregnant
pfizer told us the women in this trial
who receive a placebo will get a real
vaccine
one month after birth that's important
because it's believed
nursing mothers pass antibodies to their
newborns through breast milk
pfizer expects the results from their
trial in the summer of 2022.
anthony nikki thank you this is such an
important study i mean we've talked
about this and you've experienced it
personally yeah you know many
many expectant expectant mothers are
very nervous about this yeah this will
give them hopefully
some comfort important study and a very
personal decision yes
absolutely yeah you guys decided to do
as my wife katie decided to do she was
more worried about getting coba than she
was about the side effects that was her
calculation but everyone will come down
differently and you said when you talk
to all the doctors
all the doctors say go ahead and do it
and the cdc points it out that you know
pregnancy is considered a high-risk
category for kovit
if the immunity does transfer to the to
the baby though that's huge
that's a big yeah that's really big